nach diesem Tagesgespräch ist
interessant noch mal auf die beiden zu
schauen die gestern Abend sich nach der
Fraktionssitzung und dann am Ende der
Fraktionssitzung auch noch mal der
Presse gestellt haben
wir werden genau den Arbeitsstil der
vergangenen vier Jahre fortsetzen was
wir uns natürlich als
fraktionsstrategisch Fragen müssen ist
die strategische Aufstellung sollte die
CDU in die Opposition wandern das ist
für die AFD die vornehmliche Aufgabe wir
haben grundsätzlich in unserer Partei
diskussionsfreudige Mitglieder das hat
sich auch bei unseren Abgeordneten
niedergeschlagen
dem ist Stadt zu geben wir diskutieren
gerne und offen und dementsprechend hat
das natürlich auch Zeit gekostet aber so
ist das eben Herr gauland und ich hier
waren immer nah also vier Jahre lang
also wenn sie gesehen hätten naja gut
also naja gut wir hängen uns oft in den
Armen freudig und weil auch die
Zusammenarbeit extrem gut funktioniert
hatten wir uns immer zusammen gefreut
haben über gute Ergebnisse der
Hintergrund aber dieser Herzlichkeit war
man anderer insgesamt möchte ich
natürlich die erfolgreiche Arbeit
fortführen diese Fraktion hat Herr
gauland aufgebaut hat hier wirklich viel
geleistet und das haben wir heute
dankenswerterweise natürlich mit diesen
ehrenfraktionsstitel auch gedankt und
von daher werden wollen wir natürlich
für uns als Fraktion die nächsten vier
Jahre weitermachen wir sind sofort
arbeitsfähig das ist wichtig wir wollen
eine Vision entwickeln so dass wir auch
koalitionsfähig bzw auch in der Lage
sind bei Koalitionsgesprächen mit dabei
zu sein das ist unser Ziel wir wollen
eine klare Vision für Deutschland
entwickeln so dass die Bürger auch
wissen was erwartet die Bürger mit der
AFD und das wäre mir die nächsten vier
Jahre jetzt natürlich vorantreiben wir
haben ja natürlich auch mit unserer
unserer Votum der Mitglieder zu
berücksichtigen die sich klar für das
Tandem auch in der Bundestagswahl
ausgesprochen haben der
Spitzenkandidaten wie Sie wissen wurden
damit über 71% der Mitglieder gewählt
und ich denke das sollten wir auch
berücksichtigen wir sind eine sehr
basisdemokratische Partei das gleiche
betrifft auch den Bundesparteitag in
Dresden die eine Doppelspitze zur
Bundestagswahl dort auch wollten und das
dem ist jetzt auch die Fraktion
mehrheitlich gefolgt und deswegen finde
ich es gut dass wir genauso angetreten
sind als tandem-lösung wie 2017 mit Frau
Weidel war und das hat die Fraktion auch
mit großer Mehrheit bestätigt wir haben
die letzten vier Jahre in dem
Fraktionsvorstand kaum
stimmenunterschiede gehabt also von
daher habe ich darauf jetzt keinen
großen Wert gelegt das sage ich ganz
offen für mich ist es wichtig dass Herr
gauland dort Bestandteil ist dass er
Rederecht hat dass er uns beraten zur
Seite steht die starken Ergebnisse
motivieren ihr die westverbände deswegen
waren die starken Ergebnisse gut und wir
haben gemerkt dass wir natürlich gerade
was die Direktkandidaten angeht gerade
im ländlichen Raum gepunktet haben und
das wird sicherlich auch thematisch eine
gewisse Rolle spielen weil das sind
natürlich unsere Wähler und das ist ein
Wählerauftrag auch welche Themen wie die
nächsten vier Jahre bespielen und das
werden wir natürlich jetzt inhaltlich in
den Ausschüssen aber auch einen
Arbeitskreisen bespielen ich habe ein
Parteivorsitzenden als Tandem-Partner
ich kann mir nicht schöneres wünschen
allen können wir inhaltliche Dinge in
der Fraktion und in der Partei klären
also von daher ist es doch schön wenn
man dann Pressekonferenzen hat wo wir
uns einig sind ich halte nichts von dem
Begriff
Ämter Häufung
denn man muss das auch positiv sehen
dadurch haben sie sehr klare personelle
Überschneidung Schnittstellen die
funktionieren so dass ich auch die
Gremien deutlich besser abstimmen und
austauschen können ich sehe das positiv
und ich negativ